they say elephants have great memories
but they can soon forget about being in
certain see the 13 elephants that are
now part of the Ringling Brothers shows
we sent to the circuses center for
elephant conservation in Florida joining
over 40 others Kenneth field chairman
and CEO a fuel entertainment said when
we did so we knew we would play a
critical role in saving the endangered
Asian elephant for future generations I
literally remember being like five or
six years old going to the Ringling
Brothers Circus i think it was at
madison square garden at the time in New
York City and seeing the elephants I
thought it was like the coolest freakin
thing that these giant animals were in
the same room as us that said this is
probably a good thing right we've all
heard these insane stories about how
they treat these animals and elephants
are incredibly smart and sensitive and
probably should not be in these circuses
right right i mean yeah they have
horrible methods of getting them to do
tricks they like poke them with hard
metal objects and stuff and that's sad i
mean it but this is only elephants
they've got other animals too they've
got like tigers and lions and know about
them and bears oh my okay is Harrison
bears no I mean I you know it's the kind
of first thought I had I was like what
about all the other animals but I mean
it's a good start yeah so let's start
with that point then like does this
ultimately lead to them getting rid of
all the animals and then and then do you
lose something about what's so fun about
the circus I mean yeah you lose the
element of cruel okay i am adam i've
been against the circus I've actually
been the protester outside really for
years now i think it's horrible it's
atrocious what they do these animals I
so you're talking about for all that of
a righteous video and the fact that
honestly the fact that elephants are
finally being phased out is amazing but
you're a hundred percent right there's
still you know tigers lions I think they
have even other animals and they had
like snow Tigers and things like that
those are also endangered animals so I
you know I'm glad the elephants are
being phased out but at the same token
these other animals are not being
affected any less by this you know and
and also I don't like that they're being
phased out just eliminate them it's it's
been passed it right I mean this reminds
me of the New York City carriage horse
situation where they've been trying to
phase them out now it sounds like the
Blasio is going to make it happen but
it's like if you really want to end it
just end it and those horses as bad as
the elephants are treated to me those
horses in the middle of those cars they
can't see anything like it's and they
get hit by cars and all that do you guys
find it easier to sympathize with
animals than humans sometimes like I
definitely get that feeling like if I
see a stray dog like in the street I
feel terrible I want to do something and
yet all the time in LA you see homeless
people you see crazy people and drug
addicts and it's almost like I don't
feel that much I know that sounds sick
but it's true well I mean animals have
an innocence about them you know that
you know people maybe have done
something bad to put them in a bad
situation but you don't always know that
like I feel bad for any anything that's
like victimized in any way yeah so yeah
do you feel it with animals I don't know
what it is yeah well no you're well
you're a bit you rescue dogs and you
have like 87 cash yeah 14 lizards and an
armadillo that's your module / God rest
in peace ya know I there's something
that's always really pulled at my
heartstrings with animals yeah like you
said there it's this innocent there
unspoken for and I just really identify
with them i don't know i just want to
protect them and yeah with humans you
don't know their story i mean if i see a
child of course tree or some or an elder
you know then obviously it has a similar
reaction but you know if you're an able
bodied human i have just less natural
you know empathy towards you for that
right so i think most of us feel that
even though we have the person could
have mental problems that we don't know
about the right if you see like a 30
something year old guy there are people
that stand in the middle a cienega like
you know trying to get to California
even though they're in California I do
like and what you don't feel much
sympathy for them because you sort of
feel like it's their fault where I know
it's not always their fault of course
but animals they can you know if you
just go and I've never seen like maybe
if you through like a ceremony once I'm
behind I saw him behind like you know
montage of like people I would feel the
same but there's something about like
those eyes and
yes really wait where do you send people
to adopt dogs and stuff don't you some
people yeah I mean there's there's a
couple or you want me to put ya now God
now come on if you want to adopt an
elephant where do you go my god now I'm
totally blanking because they're
stopping want me to do it yes all right
go to where I got my dog at least in New
York the Humane Society of New York it's
not part of a bigger humane study but
the humane society itself is pretty good
how do you guys feel about zoos in
general because I went to the san diego
zoo about a year ago and i got like a
really super private tour and i was in
there with the elephants i literally
like under them and like washing their
bellies and doing all this cool stuff
and feeding giraffes and everything but
i did leave even though it was awesome
it was really awesome and seeing these
animals and all that i did leave kind of
feeling sad for them like especially
like the lions and tigers where they
were just sitting there like that [ __ ]
another day this year you know I how do
you generally even though I know they're
doing a ton of good stuff at the zoo in
there rehabilitating animals and you
know endangered species and all that
yeah and I always feel bad to see an
animal in a cage no matter what yeah
it's hard because like you know people
use the argument well they're being
taken care of there giving all the
special treatment and I hear the same
thing from my family that is very much
into horse racing you know they're like
well the horses have this better life
they're being taken care of him like
yeah but they break their leg and
they're euthanize right away you know so
it's like the higher quality of being
cared for and stuff I in my opinion
isn't as valuable is just letting them
be you know themselves in the wild right
and it's a total catch 22 of course
because you know the endangered lion
that's my treated well loses its desire
to live in some ways and his board yet
at the same time isn't under the threat
of being poached or something so I mean
you could say like if you go visit a
prison they're being taken care of by
texting you know they're protecting
being protected from society etc etc
it's the same thing in zoos unless it's
a wildlife protection you know refuge or
something like that I think zoos for the
most part are something that should also
be eliminated as well as you know like
places like SeaWorld absolutely I mean
you are
actually seeing physical responses to
captivity with you know their fins going
down with elephants pacing back and
forth yeah and they're literally going
that and then they wonder why every now
and again one of these answers is
something and then when they do they get
euthanized yeah all right so more
importantly than any of this when will
they free the clowns yes god they're
just gonna open a little car and I go
running away for their way you want the
clowns to be for you 20 counts where the
clouds people all right should we free
the Crown's let us know in the comments
right